It was sort of i was sort of out
working on minimalist thinking like
that whole minimalist thinking i was
right into that sort of quick grab
and macleans thing
and i was very very media aware because i
always looked at i mean to me was a whole
study and i got public art
and the quick grab and so
that people make it simple
as possible. Symbols and.
Simplify symbols of it becomes easier so
because you want to get through to the
mainstream the real the people that are
really out of it and somehow so twix them.
I mean that was my idea. Silently
by just creating subliminal images.
So i sort of working on
a minimalist revelant
and so i just had a simple
quote also the whole movement.
You know moving with a back
with a pack. Just one costume.
Which is easy and then i had banners
and that paints and things like
that be able to move into an area
and go to an action just the whole theater
either work out how thick the kit
and have to move in quickly
and then quickly get into it
while there's this you know
when things are happening really fast around
you just just being in it like this at
that instant sort of getting
to sort of that sort of.
You know getting into a phone box
and getting into superman costumes
that sort of scenario like you.
There you are you know like that here
appears that i felt the ethical thing.
But that was another constructs
also the fantasy my head.
You know like
that sort of like these costumes like you
turn into this type image units which
it's the piers.
Nobody knows who it is out there or
they see is this it is this image.
Is where you play it play
it up to them and. For the.
That costume. Then i started to work
the costume and i sort of fine writing
and drawing so that you know
when it's picked up on camera.
It's really clear and turn from paper
mâché didn't work too good with
that skull thing to a gas
mask consider a ccg a smart
and easily cranked up easy to get
and and it sort of it. Laughs and.
And also putting the hood and that
connection with the with with air
and breathing and pollution and so that's
symbol so as i work that idea and.
I keep working sort of i still do it.
I keep working the ideas and
the costume on the back had.
And the race or in the race when i was
working thing in the piece actions.
So my actions were were around
peace and the environment.
One costume i could interface
and as and so i worked on that
and and the dollar sign that i had the
dollar sign had sort of read on the edges
and gold which was an axe it was a dollar
axe and i use that in my mind i use
that as you know like the axons you know
like the executioner to trick you sean.
And as the dollar was there was
the weapon and but i also use
that to i played with it.
You know sort of used as a gun you just
play with the in the mind sequence of just
sort of is these props and in dance wise.
There's multiple forms
and then the then the towards then the the
whole even our life i've even developed
it even further. So you've got
it's totally environmentally.
Plugged in there doesn't even talk about
the race or in the race just says now.
You know ecological
destruction. And. On it and.
And then i got and i have
panels that go onto it.
Like can interface panels or have just a
wall writer this is the image of a wall.
I sort of in the race or in the race.
I say well this is just war and you
know missiles and. Barrels and drums.
So i built up a whole travelling kit
and a vehicle so it grew into a whole
traveling outfit show with banners
and you know so that whole process grew
and it came to a crescendo then i went
overseas whether just to take it in the
larder and rocky flats and. And you know.
Woodstock and all that
in washington and then.
I came back recently no come back recently
and feel sort of now
it's really the 90s era
and this is getting down to what why i'm
here now is actually we need to really get
down to restoration. You know.
The planet is indeed should we know
how bad it is around the place
and sort of freak the daylights you know
like with all the information freaks
that they either feel we badly
need to give people ways
or how they can restructure
their lives to heal the planet
and we need the jobs the economy has to
be around. Healing healing the planet.
It's very clear so
that we've gone through all the social
experiments we don't know things that work.
We know what's got to be done. It's not as
if we don't know what's got to be done.
We know what's not to be done.
You know not to pollute the you
know the nest that we we live from.
And we've got to and we've got to stop
fighting one another in cooperating
and on this to make this.
World habitable for everybody.
That that is.
Well that's what the great one of the
green movement in general is this the is
that movement. It's it's growing more.
I mean i'm involved with earth repair
at the moment i mean i've always been
involved with the earth repair foundation
cause i'm frank scarf from the united
nations day because.
I'm also interested in changing the symbols
of the united nations flag because
united nations is needs drastic reforming.
And if it needs to recognize
that we have ngos
and we've got to have an ngo ngos not not
nation states running the show by the
ngos as as a forum of decision
making non-government organizations
but it be people's basic as we've got
more people moving away from governments
and making decisions as the power brokers
but actually things come on forums like
people in a place you know groups like
greenpeace and communicate abroad in
friends of the earth and a whole mallee
and that's growing more and
more it is a people's movement.
And so those social groups coming
up from the grassroots and from.
Different groups from different places
around where people empower themselves are
the people for exercising
that power these decisions.
Come out feed themselves through government
sure you have the government things
but the ngos have to be. Listened
to and has to be a major forum.
I mean you don't go. And it's growing more
and more say i want to see the united.
You know. Like you know
what a nations really and
that they're beginning to move
that they do have certain
ngos in the united nations
and the last earth conference the first
big first summit that was ngo organised.
So it was a big big part for
non-government organisations now.
Yeah that's a spiritual base is really
important because that's where we get all we
talk. We've been involved with the
materialistic world. Right. Well the material.
Well i'm through meditation
and my you know my experience through
meditation sort of made me aware
that we live in a world of illusion.
I mean i am involved allusion.
So that
that holds the spiritual connection you
sort of grew actually being here in you
know from my experiences i mean the whole
experience has been experience to be
about the whole you know i actually did
these things totally out of for my
own.
You know like what happen inside of me you
know i think certainly brought me out.
I mean.
It's just a gut experience i mean i didn't
know what i was entering into it just
these things came to me it's almost like i
was like the messengers i was sort of i
was just part of the process
and sort of linking up with
other people in this process
and this is there's a whole lot
of stuff written about in spirit.
I was sort of looked at it. I mean
it's the shambala warrior type race
and the warrior rainbow
warriors and things like that.
Yeah well they're all sort of like we need
people i talk about people coming on the
earth and rescuing the
situation from the dark ages.
You know that's sort of
destroying the planet
and it's well in swill been
written before like a sword.
How many in sings and and you cannot
sort of i mean you look at it
and it's there and so that that became
you know sort of like sort of joined
that bandwagon and sort of
creating being part of that that.
That movement in my lifestyle
but the spiritualities from
observe ing around you
that you know you become aware
that you connected on one thing
and then you also that
that you also just there's
this whole like you actually
is right there in the here and now.
And you're observing and you desire
to be keen sense of observation
but it's still allusion. Because you. See
and hear things but it's not really.
It's not tangible it's still
allusion area it's elusive.
And so i mean i've come away of that
and saw that ask that connection
that you become they connect that you
connect that and then the earth.
He's a living entity in itself you
know that's that's a living entities
and i was at arco santiago in
that spirituality i learned
that all matter is spirit and i see that
the paint there is actually living.
It's what everything all matter is
and when we get down to recycling
and all the rest of it.
The rescue of the planet will
become that awareness that
that everything that's made and
everything that's produced.
I mean it's farfetched thinking you might
think to some people but to me fix
that everything is recyclable.
Everything has a place in the universe
in this whole thing is just knowing just
becoming aware that it is this
matter is very small matter is.
His spirit and it's it's
it's a living entity.
And you know when you're in that
meditation so you become aware that.
That's your water an area.
You know you you have your heart
when you're shitting and pissing
and all the rest of you just realize
that you're just like another animal
and you're an animal just like and
but you've got to this other thing here
at the global brain thing you know a
connection up can't put your finger
on it but there is that connection.
I mean i travel from here to america
and i see the same people
doing the same thing.
The same connection i can see saying people
connect up in australia doing exactly
the same even look alike.
I mean i don't know why
but i don't know how
but you can see are type images talk about
art talk without any costumes just doing
things. Exactly the same slow global brain
you know is that connection. No answers.
No no. I mean it's just
there. If you observe it.
You can see it is going to
people talk about guide
and all the rest of not
going to stand that.
And i can say
or it's all relevant because if you don't
then not you just go sort of squash
everybody's like this is the way in the
only way we say you know to me i say you
know develop your own process and
then keep keep keep keep an open mind
and i say i'm sort of i'm sort
of right in the gaia principle.
In that that's a living earth and.
And then i feel that we can
hit we can heal the world.
I mean is the healing we've just got
to be aware of what's destroying
and really stop that and find solutions
i'm just keeping my fingers crossed.
But if if it does go at least. I mean
it's you know goes for you personally.
You don't it doesn't end life in general
because all matter is spirit will be the
world will go on like the
universe will go on because.
Plants have come and gone and so forth.
So we can have that sort
of get away from the earth
but at the moment i live on the
earth. I'm going to try my best.
To to be evolved person in this time.
Yeah it's a great useful tool. I mean it
wasn't till yeah well that mine and mine.
The mine drugs are out of it's time
was very real. I mean that's true.
I mean the mind drugs.
I well i've experienced it
before queries because i was i.
First it was i was overseas in 1960 69
and i was in london after slammin the whole
sort of acid acid house thing in their
school so i become aware of things and
then melbourne's artists and cause
that sort of a changed me.
I moved away from my my tribal connections
with the family so moved away from those
sort of roots
and start things sort of there's you know
you find yourself in relating to seeing
things you seen elude talking about it's
illusionary you state your mind start
seeing different things and it sort
of made you aware of certain senses
and heightened senses and so forth but.
It also became i was sort
of it was very special.
I really realized that community
that cultures in the past was a
part of a spiritual connection.
No they didn't go and just drop
pills in their mouth all the time
and we sort of abused it.
That's where we've lost it in our western
society it's a consumerist society
and people want to have the hit
all the time it was not made for
that was made for special rituals and
certain people used to not want people
and went through an initiation to
get there to be that and to use it.
For those sort of special
events so to become aware
but in this sort of world
we sort of moved away
and that's sort of you know that's how it
is i mean i can't say it's good or bad.
I say
that it as experience is good provided
people know how to put the brakes on a gaza
was it becomes destructive.
Just so it has been a useful
tool and and and still well
and i don't do it these days
but i wouldn't say that.
You know like the door the pens on sort
of i went through a sort of lindsay camp
idea doing be tripping on acid.
While on stage going on foot is.
What i used to do that if the i used
to. I went through a stage of. Of.
Tripping on stage while performing i did
all the rehearsals without all of that
and did all my stuff in the
trip and and then i do things
that i do things like i'll be on stage
and i said i get an idea of getting
something i'll go off stage
and get this thing you know
see something in the audience
and bring it up on stage
you know the things
that are totally freed me up because it's
just became this whole thing i was just.
You know things were stretched out time
was stretched out there was no fear.
You know took away all that there
was i was part of a whole carnival
and performance when i was performing
i was i was the centre of attraction.
The world. I was sent that with
the other people around me
but it was very i found it very useful
in terms of my growth spiritual growth.
Yeah well that's that's well it's
a living carnal living theatre.
It's a main street in itself as a main
street and that's how i've been to see
that since aquarius first
of all and paying it up.
Was there in doing it up so that it's a
billboard for that to keep it like that.
And so.
So it's sort of maintain that that's a good
thing about the murals that i done is.
It sort of keeps that link as a.
As i see a trickle fafsa help that
part of it but the only other thing is
that the people that come here
like theatre like people.
Perform there they dress
up in a certain way
and it sort of shock the different daylights
out of different people the way they
behave but it's there because they want
to say well. This is how i feel you know.
And. And it's just it's
it's sort of been left.
Somehow it's been a place where
that's what i'm grateful that name
and has been a place where people can bring
along their different ideas which are
totally not in in line with the with
the smooth running cogs of society
and and creates is this tension this
thing for problems to be solved
but this is the world out
there coming to an end
and which is a theatre a little small
little amphitheatre you know the globe
theater that you walk into without any.
Rehearsals you just come in
there's people to bring their.
Their particular being
and perform it in different ways.
Yeah that was just carries
on. Yeah carries on.
You know what that it carries on and.
Yeah. When you have you just look around.
It's the billboard door
boards all kinds of things
that are happening around the place for
one thing it's a billboard limit is a
billboard as a. As well as a.
Big forum controversial forum of new ideas
which is made itself into mainstream.
And next week we've got the eco conference
and i think i tourism as establish
that identity and what an
indian is and hopefully.
I mean it's whatever the decision is
going to be made liminal still be
that because that's how it's
perceived outside. Anyway.
People are aware of what it
is the artistic creative
and spiritual.
Shamans in the world
they know what it means
and if we're the ones who have been
here they just say this is great. Yes.
If you tune into a kitchen
into that energy.
It's there for others it's a total dismal.
That but we've got to really
try and make people aware
that it's it's really it's it's it's just
one place in the world which is very
important for the world the way it is
so real gem and got to be grateful
that we had a aquarius festival.
And we need to celebrate it which is sort
of just to bring out all the. What it.
You know what it. You know what it did
and house developed up to now and just
that whole culture and
what we are developing
and our celebration is what we're
developing towards 2010 the 21st.
Well might. My hope for the fear
that that named and becomes.
Well in the main street. I'd
like to see turn into a more.
And and the traffic redirected out.
Just on the physical level like we
do get funding to do things. How.
Alternative ideas that are dreamt up
that really work well for here do happen
even though it's terribly expensive to do
that that we can do it.
Because a lot of things.
Gets short circuited because they
are because it's too expensive
but they can if people put their heart
and soul into like governments say like.
You know. Let's do it.
It's a good idea
that all the drug issue in the mainstream
would be totally change if this becomes.
You know a walk thoroughfare with all
kinds of people cultures which it will be
once it becomes a more it'll be a lot
more people walking all kinds of cultures
already changing nipponese changing.
That whole thing that of him
and just being sort of.
That's just that was a particular. And i'll
be just another scene which will. Well.
We need to find problem.
Solutions to helping people
that are really drug you know
creative you know really screwed up
and hopefully putting you know the
whole drug issues put into perspective
perspective especially that.
You know marijuana for instance you know
and just suppression of information.
What it is and then
that education would put it above put it
on level doesn't go underground because
people are destroying themselves
with fear and and and
and they being the being manipulated
the being being exploited
by criminal elements.
Not not not by korean elements by
elements which owing to the greed same
greed that i portray people into quick
money to do the chopping down forests.
And to for it's.
For wood shipping and so
for multinational level
and getting a quick get as much out
of the environment or polluting.
So
that they you know just just so they can make
money just the whole thing is just making
money out of drugs
and it's the same sort of mentality of
people just exploiting unexploited people by
giving them. Stuff that
they shouldn't be give.
And but they can't be and
the only way you can.
Change that situation is first
of all to make it totally bleak.
Because police are involved as well as
governments involved with the whole
distribution of drugs petrol chemical
companies make it the whole drug pop talk
popping drugs thing is not just about.
About smoking and that is it's
always been with these drugs
and the only way that you can
be mystified is education
and is a better way of living.
And i emphasize the positive of you can
do away with it. I mean subprocess you.
Certain people have
gone on it. Get off it.
And get on with you know not destroying
themselves it would so all rescue them
beforehand by saying hey
you know. We don't.
These are the alternative
try these things out.
You know you've got two people come to
nimbin looking for seeking a change.
You know it's a it's a refuge.
It's a refuge to neiman's a
refuge for four people that are.
Of had it had it really bad out there in
the in the world into sort of a kind of
place at all in place so i mean
these issues have to be addressed
and as there's no simplistic answer because
we're dealing with the whole world.
Global brain thinking about it.
So we just got to look what other people
how other people are dealing with the drug
drug issues and how it's changing and
helping to change the law and these ideas
and hopefully nimal come up with an
innovative idea to try out to. To.
To change the situation here. I've got
my ideas of. You know communities and.
Where people can plant trees and. You
know things for an environment and.
Hang around music around it
and i'd like the whole thing of festival
continuous festival but they can.
They doing things for the environment
living on the earth and they're doing.
Things in these sort of getting volvic
that sort of integrate themselves
with with a culture that's
one thing i mean and
this. And just infinite.
Ideas of that sort of creative
living creative living
and healing ourselves because the whole
thing aquarius was about survival.
I mean it was that the whole key thing of
the craft festival was crying crying out.
We are destroying ourselves you know wars
destroying the in the the pollution is
like we were aware of the
pollution in the city
and it is out the back
straight through. So.
We've got to save you know like save the
planet that's the key phrase of save the
earth of woodstock at the moment you
know the woodstock. For instance and.
But that that's that's it.
We need to become healers on the earth
and so we've got a lot
of knowledge developed
and got to keep developing because
we haven't got a lot of strength
and our individual.
Energy and be brave and.
And an exercise your. Your
communication skills.
Rise
and i hope everybody puts energy towards
next year's aquarius not it's not just about
a festival it's about
celebrating a period in time
and a milestone in time so the
ideas come out of the community.
You know all forms of the community.
I mean a government people come
out and and put on a forum
or want to forum about government.
You know to get together with
about alternative government and.
And so forth and have it as
part of the celebration.
Anyone just under the banner of
aquarius foundation. 3:5 forward.
Her plug for. They're critical
foundation. But their careers.
Next year is
and through the no news by getting touch
with members is to get in touch in never
news and that that
that women use is a good
a good a good connection
with development of the
thinking of members.
So if people really want to know
how nimble it is been developing
and is subscribed in then when
you is post office box name and.
To a 9 thing like three to one.
You know post office member.
So that's.